so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your host
Carl SM and today we're talking about
bredas Sparta's greatest General and as
with all of the videos here at
biographics this one is based on an
article submitted To Us by a member of
our writing team that being Ru
Alexander the year 431 was an important
one for Greece because it marked the
beginning of the greatest internal
conflict that completely reshaped the
ancient Greek world the pelian War it
went on for decades and sought to decide
once and for all who was the top dog
Athens or Sparta the answer
Sparta spoilers for those who didn't
know it did happen like 2400 years ago
and we're not here to talk about the war
itself though but rather a role that one
man played in it bedus of Sparta one of
the most decorated officers in the city
state's
history calling the conflict the pelian
war is a little confusing because there
was actually an earlier war between the
same sides more or less that is referred
to as the first pipian war that lasted
from 460 to 445 BC however because the
second conflict lasted longer and had a
much more decisive impact it sort of
default to becoming the pelian war so
what were the signs during this little
dust up we had Athens versus Sparta of
course we also had their respective
allies Sparta led the pelian league a
loose Confederation of allies of Greek
states that been around for about a
century by the time of our war meanwhile
Athens formed the Delian League in 478
BC unsurprisingly with itself at the
head of the table the Delian League
mostly consisted of coastal and Island
City States and ostensibly it came into
existence to protect the Greek World
against the Persian threats however it
also allowed Athens to climb the pecking
order pretty fast and after only a few
decades it was butting heads with Sparta
over who the number one power spot ranks
was conflict between the two sides was
inevitable especially considering one
side had Spartans on it as we said the
initial Clash ended in 445 BC without a
clear winner following the signing of
the 30-year peace treaty but 30 years
was way too optimistic because just a
few years later tensions were already
starting to rise again the main catalyst
for renewed hostilities between the two
Greek Powers ended up being a war
between the two completely different
city stakes on one side there was
Corinth a major member of the pelian
league and on the other there was the
Island City of corer better known today
as coru which is allied with Athens at
first Athens offered a defensive
Alliance claiming that they would engage
Corinthian ships if they tried to invent
corer but would otherwise not get
involved but Athens did get involved and
ultimately so did Sparta which meant it
was time for war
again so nearby Brad I'm going to let
Pascal take a break now and come in and
tell you a story I recently got a new
phone I was really excited to get a new
phone not for any of the new bells and
whistles that were present on it but
because getting a new phone meant
getting a new phone number and for a
couple of weeks there was Bliss and then
one day I really wanted a pizza so I
ordered a pizza put my number in on the
website form the next day the spam call
started it's a story as old as time was
it at least a good pizza it wasn't now
that's what made it worse it came cold
and when I called him up to say I
ordered it without um like mushrooms on
it and said oh sorry we closed and how
many spam calls would you say you get
per week at least three or four yeah
it's every single day for me I don't
think my phone has been off silent since
I got it because just every time I'm
recording my phone will go off because
there's some company somewhere who got
my phone number from some place or
another decided to give me a call in the
middle of the work day CU they think I'm
going to buy their product cuz that's no
no one's ever done that and I hate it if
only there was a service that allowed me
to just tell each and every single one
of those companies to leave me the hell
alone well you'll be happy to know about
today's sponsor then Carl segue so go on
tell me about today's sponsor rles so
today's video is sponsored by Aura so
Aura is a service that does exactly what
we've been talking about today they get
in contact with the data brokers who
hold your information the ones who steal
it from websites and sell it on and they
tell these people to get rid yes and you
might think well surely I can do that
myself and you can but if you any idea
how many companies have your information
it's a lot because something these like
data scraping companies do is they sell
their data to each other so there could
theoretically be dozens if not hundreds
of separate companies who have access to
this information and going through each
one individually is to put it simply a
pain in the ass they also don't make it
very easy to do oh I know this have you
ever tried unsubscribing from a gym
membership Brad the good thing about
Aura as well is it isn't just a service
that does this okay so what else does
Aura do because obviously like that
alone is pretty valuable to me of
someone who you know appreciates their
time and their privacy as a YouTube
content creator my privacy is basically
forfeit at this point and I I get that
people are going to like follow me on
social media but I don't want companies
knowing where I am well I'll just go
through the other features while you
play with your um like flick my snoot
what is it again it's an anti it's an
anti look at how can you not tell it's
an anti I forgot I forgot the word look
how ripped it is it's like but Aura also
offers an antivirus yes a VPN yes
password management and more see that's
all very good it's an allinone app that
just takes care of all these things so
rather than having five different apps
that do all this things you can have one
that's an all in on just you know a fire
and forget if you will so you can either
let people continue to exploit and
profit off your private information or
you can figuratively tell them to do one
by going to aura.com
biographics to start your twoe free
trial we've also provided the link below
in the description and I feel like snoo
is fast becoming a fixture of my
presenting on biographics Geographics
and its sister channel so let's let's
just give snoo's moment and get some
spiral on that an shall
we yeah got him that's a good catch I'm
back oh W get some spiral on that an
eater
good and thus the pelian War Began
pitting the thesome span infantry
against the naval superiority of Athens
this conflict lasted so long it was
broken up into separate phases and we're
actually only going to be covering the
first phase here known as the academian
war after the Spartan King academus II
since that is the only one that bredes
took part in because as your mat found
out he kicked some ass during that first
phase in fact he kicks so much ass
during that war that he gained a
reputation as one of the greatest
commanders Sparta had ever seen the main
source of his long conflict was the
historian fides who actually serve as a
general in the war and would later write
an account of it up until the year 411
BC that's the kind of firsthand account
that we rarely get with ancient history
but even though Theses was known to be
pretty impartial he was an Athenian
after all so we know which side he was
rooting for plus as we're about to find
out he was not a fan of bredas and for
good reason so just keep that in mind as
we recount everything we're about to say
speaking of our protagonist we first
join him in media res at the outbreak of
the war in 431 BC at a Coastal Village
called methon there's not much we can
say about him before the war it's not
like the Spartans were known for their
extensive record keeping all we know is
it was a son of a man named Tellis who
was a spartiate AKA a for citizen of
Sparta plutar also gave pra's mother's
name as and I hope I pronounced this
correctly aelan Onis although he lived
almost 500 years later so we're not
really sure how he knew brettus's
mother's name but there we go as we and
Zack Snyder have said Sparta had a
pretty strong infantry while Athens had
the advantage on the sea obviously each
side would have preferred to fight on
its home turf so to speak so their early
strategies involved trying to go the
other one into a disadvantageous battle
therefore the Spartan King academus took
his troops into ateka the region of
Greece where Athens is located while the
Athenian Fleet sailed around the pelian
peninsula and attack coastal towns to
create strife and Rebellion for Sparta
one of those coastal towns were the
aforementioned methon which made for a
juicy Target for Athens since it did not
have a Garrison and its walls were
pretty weak the Athenians laid Siege and
were surely expecting to gain entry in a
matter of days if not sooner we not for
the actions of bredas he was in charge
of a small force of aund hites for
soldiers armed with Spears and Shields
whove been tasked with guarding the
district upon hearing of the attack on
methon predus rushed in and took
advantage of the scattered Athenian Army
that was mainly focused on the wall was
not expecting an attack from behind the
hites successfully made their way
through the enemy ranks and entered the
town to reinforce it at this early stage
of the war the Athenians were not
interested in a prolonged Siege even if
they still outnumber the Spartans 10 to1
they wanted to get in and get out so in
bredas made that impossible they decided
to pick up sticks and leave Anthony
alone his Swift actions earned bredas an
honor known as the thanks of Sparta thus
becoming the first officer to gain this
distinction in the pelian
war
following his initial Triumph at methon
bedus took part in several important but
not necessarily crucial moments in the
war more or less sliding nicely into
whatever role was needed of him his next
task was to act as an adviser of sorts
or symbolis to cemes an admiral who
commanded the Spartan Fleet during the
first years of the conflict you might
think this was a step down for the
legendary braus but it was more of a
punishment for cemes who met his first
Naval encounter against Athens with
failure even when he was against a
smaller enemy Fleet and there was no
dishonor greater for a Spartan than
losing against a smaller opposing Force
therefore to ensure he didn't lose again
he was sent not one not two but three
Commissioners to make sure he got the
job done braus timates and lerron he was
told in no uncertain terms do not screw
up again for the next battle the
Spartans plan to take Retreat and La the
Athenian Fleet comprised about 20
vessels into a straight and it worked
sort off the enemy Fleet led by a guy
named formo took the bait and followed
the Spartans into the narrow Water by
the time they realized what had happened
the Spartans had turned around and
pressed the attack 11 Athenian ships
managed to escape but nine were sunk it
was a great result for initial encounter
but the Spartans got too cocky too fast
wanting to sink another enemy ship one
Spartan vessel sailed ahead of the
others but the Athenians did some fancy
maneuvering turned around struck the
Spartans ship and sunk it instead one of
the three Commissioners Tim mcraes was
aboard that vessel and as it plunged
into the water he committed suicide out
of Shame all the other Spartan shits
panicked and while trying to turn around
too quickly some of them ran ground
While others took their tails between
their legs and sail to Corinth in safer
Waters ultimately though both sides
claim victory in that battle though
neither one truly covered itself in
glory that is likely why cemus and brus
settled on a risky plan to attack the
port of Athens itself perus they were
going to sail from Corinth to Meera in
ateka and from there launched a naval
attack on pereus thinking that the port
would not be heavily guarded since the
Athenians would not expect a strike
right at the heart of their Naval
headquarters and they were right and
their plan very well might have worked
but for unknown reasons the Spartans
chickened out at the last moment and
opted instead to attack the Athenian
port on the island of cnis and this was
successful it's just that pereus would
have been a much bigger prize common
thinking suggests that cemus and brus
didn't want to go back home without one
solid Victory under their belt so they
just took what they could get braedius
his next engagement came in 427 BC when
he once again acted as symbola this time
to a guy named and again I hope I
pronounce this correctly alas who was
trying to put down rebellion in corser
but for whatever reason the kerans
decided to act against the advice of
Spartans when it came to defending
against a much greater enemy Force so
when bredas heard that the Athenian
fleet was approaching he basically said
screw this I'm going home and left the
city to their fate brus then showed up
at the Battle of pyos in 425 BC which
ended up being a decisive victory for
Athens even though brus himself was
single out for bravery with which he
fought plutar gives us a quick account
which almost certainly didn't happen the
way he tells it but it's just too badass
not to include the historian says that
during a battle a spear penetrated
through b' shield and pierced him and at
that point Bas pulled out the spear and
killed his opponent using his own weapon
later when asked how he was injured brus
replied in typical laconic Spartan
fashion when my shield betrayed
me in 42 4 BC it was tied for bredas to
cast off the kid gloves no more advising
other guys he was given command to his
own Army and sent to th to cause some
trouble but before he sat on his way he
heard of an incoming attack on marara so
he sailed from there first and together
with the boans and the megarians managed
to drive back the Athenians from there
predus traveled to thessaly where he met
up with an ally King picus II of Macedon
and there's a lot of Greek words coming
up so he's going to go nice and slowly
through this next section folks like you
know bear with me the king wanted to
fight his neighbors the lysan led by
King arabas but predus had other ideas
he wasn't there to settle a personal
Grudge instead he asked for an audience
the Lan because even though he was a
Spartan and not really one for long
speeches even his greatest critics were
forced to admit he wasn't a bad speaker
during this meeting he persuaded them to
revolt against Athens it didn't really
take though and just a year later the
lysan switch sides again and with
reinforcements defeated the macedonians
and the Spartans in battle all of these
were just side quests though and nothing
to do with predus as end gwiin th he was
there to take anolis a key City in the
region and he did quite easily in fact
he laid Siege and because he knew the
enemy reinforcements were on the way
predus offered generous terms of
surrender guaranteeing the safety of
those who wanted to leave and allowing
those who stayed to keep their property
the people of antholis were happy with
this Arrangement turns out they weren't
really fans of Athens that much anyway
allegedly only hours after brus entered
the city the Athenian reinforcements AR
led by his longtime rival thusis himself
Athens was Furious with the loss of
anolis and put the entire blame on fuses
who was brought to trial and charged
with again hopefully I pronounce this
correctly prosia which basically meant
he'd failed as a general thusis was
found guilty and sent into exile for 20
years thus ending his part in the war
and this story Reedus's involvement
would also end shortly thereafter
following the loss of antholis the two
sides agreed to a one-year Armistice
once it ended in 422 BC though Cleon one
of the most prominent Athenian generals
March the thust saying determined to
take back the city again and here is
where BEDA showed that fearsome
reputation the Spartans had well earned
although the two sides were about even
Cleon preferred to wait for
reinforcements trapped inside the city
predus reason that if they were going to
just sit around and do nothing they
would almost certainly lose so instead
he opened the gate and led a sudden
audacious charge right into the center
of the enemy Force the gamble was a
stunning and rousing success the
Athenians were left shocked panicked and
confused and broke ranks to run away
because I can't imagine there were many
SS it's more terrifying on the ancient
Battlefield than a bunch of Spartans
running directly towards you ready to
stab you Cleon himself was killed in
this battle and the day was one there
was just one problem though bredas had
been mortally wounded during the
fighting he survived long enough to
receive word of their Victory and then
died and was buried as a hero in
amphipolis after both Spartan and Athens
had lost two of their best Generals in
one battle they signed a peace treaty in
421 BC it didn't last and the pelian war
resumed who knows if you like this video
maybe we'll cover sander another one of
the top Spartan leaders and bring the
war to its conclusion if you want to see
more videos like this you can like the
video if you got any comments your
favorite Spartan quotes any favorite
like you know figures from that point in
history he wants to cover on another
episode we can do that if you want to
see more subscribe and check out like
the sister channels to um uh biographics
in particular top 10s and go check out
like you know my um smooth headed
predecessor talking about some badass
Spartan quote some articles I wrote like
five six years ago I know I'm certainly
going to go look them back up to see
which ones I forgot butchered and or
didn't mention in this video either way
hope everyone watching this has the day
that they deserve and as always
cheers